.
>> Carley: CHECK IT OUT.
REPUBLICANS ARE GETTING THE LAST
LAUGH, "NEW YORK TIMES" OP ESHG
D ARGUE LEFT-LEANING COMEDIANS
ARE STRUGGLING TO ATTRACT
AUDIENCES AND COMMENTATORS ARE
THRIVING.
>> Todd: SCHOLARS WHO STUDY
POLITICAL COMMUNICATION AND
HUMOR, THEY ARE FUN PEOPLE, FIND
LIBERALS ARE IRONIC SMARTALECS
AND THERE ARE MORALISTS.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA JOINS US
NOW, JOE, GUTFELD IS KILLING IT
AND YOU NEED LOOK NO FURTHER
THAN FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO
SAID THAT DEMOCRATS ARE A BUZZ
KILL.
>> Joe: YEAH, CAN I REPEAT
QUESTION TODD JUST ASKED OR IDEA
HE BROUGHT UP?
YOU ARE SAYING THERE ARE
SCHOLARS THAT STUDY COMEDY?
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
>> Todd: GREAT QUESTION.
>> Joe: YOU GO TO COMEDY AND YOU
LAUGH, I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
BEGIN, STEPHEN COLBERT, SETH
MYERS, TREF NOAH OFFER OUTRAGE.
SATIRE LEFT THE BUILDING SOME
TIME AGO, THE SHOWS ARE SO
PREDICTABLE BECAUSE OF MY OPENIA
OVER DONALD TRUMP.
CHECK OUT THIS STUDY FROM GEORGE
MASON UNIVERSITY, IT FOUND THAT
97% OF THE JOKES WERE TOLD ABOUT
TRUMP, BY COLBERT AND FALLON
ALONE, JIMMY FALLON, 455 JOKES
ABOUT TRUMP AND JUST 14 ABOUT
JOE BIDEN, WHO PROVIDES AMPLE
COMEDIC MATERIAL ON A DAILY
BASIS.
IT IS WHY GUTFELD BEATS ALL OF
THEM, DESPITE HAVING THE CASE OF
JIMMY KIMMEL.
IT IS BECAUSE GREG HAS FOUND HIS
NICHE AUDIENCE, THAT IS
TWO-THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Todd: GUTFELD IS FUNNY, I
SPEND THE ENTIRE TIME LAUGHING.
THE OTHER SHOWS, I AM TOLD ARE
ABYSMALLY NOT FUNNY, MAYBE BE
FUNNY IF YOU ARE A LATE NIGHT
COMEDY SHOW.
CRAZY, TODD.
POSSIBLE END TO AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION CAUSING A STIR.
AMERICAN ENEMIES DON'T NEED TO
DO ANYTHING, REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING IT ON THEIR OWN AND
ANOTHER CRITIC CLAIMING MY
COUNTRY IS DYING.
WHY ARE PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT A
TRUE MERITOCRACY RETURNING?
>> Joe: BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
USED TO IT FOR SO LONG, SEEING
THINGS GOING THE OTHER WAY IN
ERM ITS OF REWARDING PEOPLE FOR
WORK AND COMMITMENT TO CRAFT,
INSTEAD OF LOOKING THROUGH A
PRISM OF COLOR.
THIS COUNTRY WOULD LOOK
DIFFERENT IN HILLARY CLINTON WON
IN 2016, BUT TRUMP GOT TO CHOOS
GORSUCH, BRETT KAVANAUGH AND AMY
CONEY BARRETT, BUT HERE WE ARE.
IT GETS WORSE IF -- BY
CONTROLLING THE SENATE, YOU
CONTROL WHO GETS CONFIRMED
DESPITE WHO IS IN THE OVAL
OFFICE, EITHER WAY, IF WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLAYOFF, MAJOR SADS, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT PEOPLE SEE COMING
WITH THE ELECTION AND ELON MUSK
TAKING OVER TWITTER.
IT IS DEPRESSING PLACE TO BE
ONLINE RIGHT NOW.
EVERYBODY IS WHINING AND
COMPLAINING AND IT IS LIKE LATE
NIGHT COMEDY.
>> Carley: AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS
RACE-BASED ADMISSION TO COLLEGE
AND SUPREME COURT IS REVIEWING A
CASE WHETHER OR NOT TO END THAT.
IF THEY DO, IT WOULD BE NO RACE
INVOLVED, NO QUESTIONS ON WHAT
YOUR RACE IS, IT WOULD
SPECIFICALLY BE YOUR GRADES AND
MERIT BASED, LIKE TODD SAID.
IF SUPREME COURT VOTES TO
OVERTURN THIS RACE-BASED
ADMISSIONS, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE REACTION ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WILL BE?
>> Joe: THE SAME AS THE DOBBS
DECISION AS FAR AS ABORTION IS
CONCERNED.
EVERYBODY IS SCREAMING FOR
EQUALITY IN THIS COUNTRY, THIS
IS AS EQUALITY AS IT GETS WHEN
IT IS NO LONGER BASED ON RACE,
HOW ARE YOUR GRADES, WHAT
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES DO
YOU DO, DO YOU DESERVE TO GO TO
COLLEGE?
EVERYBODY WOULD BE BEHIND THAT,
THAT IS NOT THEIS CA, GUYS.
>> Todd: PEOPLE ON THE LEFT